MANU RAJUTHANK YO
REPORTING.
>>AVBREWS FROMPREME CO C SCHNEIF
E DID THE COURT DECIDEHIOT
ITROSUES IN THE E OFOC
ER BY R OFF THE  ISSD Y LATEHAET
TEAM.
SAS OFF-CAUSH
AND CODNOL HERE.
THIS IS ANECIT WAS JUSCE THOMA
HERE
AGAIN, WE'RE
OE JUST COMING TOGE RULIN IS A
VIN SCHOOL PUNISHED HEUSE OF
F CAMPUS SPEHIOUT, IT SAYS THER
CA
THE SUPREMURT  THING
LIKE
THOFF-CA SH
WENT TOO FAR ADITHPRIS WAS A SNS
HAD CREED I SOMNEAFFILIIN
CHRL
'S HOW TSOPHOMORE GOT IN TROUBL.
THE SUPREME COURT REALLY
THAT
SCHOOL DISTRICT HAD GONE TOOHE.
OUT SAYING THAT THE PUNINT
HERELLY JUSTN'FIE
CR
INARANAUGH
OUTSPOKENN
IS
INCAUS COACHES
GIRLS BASKETBALL, SO HE S T ATE
ATING STEAM.
CAMPUS? SAID, IF ATE , DING MEO
MILLIONS WOULDSHED
RIS.
BECAUSE THIS COMES AA TIME
THO ON SOCDIA NO MATE ENT, ANDTN
ORLD, ITAN
INSTANTA REFLECTED
CKCAMPUS.
CAMPUS ORT OF THE LINE THHEJUSN
VIAL MEDIA, IT CAN
WHAT HAPPENS ON
THAT'S WHY THEY'RE
THIS BROAD S SAYING SCHOOLS
S IT'S BULLYING ORGE.
IS
REALLY JUST, IE WORD KAVANAUGH
SCHOOL DISTRICT,CA
ER FREE SP
JES, R LL FOR US.
N IT.
S.
OPEYER WITH E
AM SURPRISED.
THESE CASEGA FAMOUS
CASE IF DES MOINESIOWAA STUDENTE
PTETNR AND SHE WADIIP
THE SUPREME COSA STUS
HAVEIGHTS EXCEPT
T'SRUPTIVE.
AL ST CASES HAVE
BEEN ABOUT WER
A LONG SOFSE
MOST OF THEBUENTS TS HAVE
UNAN 8-1E WOI HAVE TO SAY,T Y.
F F SOFTBALLLLARAPHRASE 'T
CHEER,
I BELIEVE THE STUDENT SPEAKING .
TIMENT HEON EXPRESSED A THINKR A
ORA
ARGUMENT SAID, LOOK,
COMMUNICATE, LARGELYOU
SO'RE NOIN DISCIPLINEMESTHE
LIKE BULLYING.
IN FRANKLY, THISA
GREAT OP
ITT AN  STEPHRER CAN
HE ALL THE WO S STUDENT WH
E D BACK ON N CK THE OTHER DAY.
STRAIGHT 6-3 SX SOLID
ER LIBERALS
ALGOEEN, HAVE YOU NO OR AM
>> IL T YOSO COMINETIO
PE
THAT'SS  I'LL GONCAA CASE WACLOO
UNANIMS. SOCIAL ISSUES. H VOTIN
IT'SANDING BECAUF WHAT ON S T T
WH GINS
WI VOTING RIGH.
BO KUMBA
MOMENTS
THESE DIVVSIL AN
OSE-TO-UNANILYBUT LET'S HOLD OFT
OUYOU,VERLAP COM.
SCIUTTO
AT HAPPE W
I HEAR YOU.E GO, CA YOU
ABOUT BREYER W T ALLALWH TER HDE
U POINTEOUT.
HA BIGSONG IN HILASTE  WE WILL T
OR
OP BECAUSE HE
SHOW JUSTICE
YOU'RE STILL AMEMBER